au soir les enfants
bonsoir j'ai bien l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui petit louis et mirabel
jouent aux marchands et à la marchande
bilan gros morceau tu devrais bien
descendre m'acheter un kilo de sables
fins aux fautes patron un peu de
chocolat aussi non non non non non ce
n'est pas la peine un tout petit peu
seulement aux propos très peu de
confiture pour le monsieur oui même typo
s'il vous plaît madame vous voulez de la
salés et sucrés au boston meilleur on va
aux fraises pain je vais m'occuper de
vous tout de suite et ça fait combien
madame mirabel ça fait plus franc
monsieur
[Musique]
voilà madame revel merci et moi madame
je voudrais 1 kg de chocolat et du bon
merci madame l'épicière oil va attendre
offre un franc où il est dur ce chocolat
à la marche 1
j'ai oublié prendre du café aussi un
oeuf à la coque voilà monsieur les
meilleurs cafés 1,6 et 1,9 qu il ya pas
d orange
j'en ai deux belles bien rouge à au
ballon mais demont 3 kg 3 olalala
méconnu mais il est vraiment dure se
connaît madame je te met d'emblée trop
dur ce chocolat je me suis tassé toutes
mes dents rôle c'est ce chocolat qui est
trop dur je me suis fait mal aux dents
ou un morceau c'était pas du vrai
chocolat les palmes à l'anarchie le
petit coquin
vous m'avez encore fait drôle de blague
attendait coach vous a travaillé non
attendez que je vous attrape vous avez
bien raison la prochaine fois je ferai
attention
bonne nuit petit coquin
[Musique]
pauvre gros ours
il est tellement gourmand qu'il n'a même
pas regardé si c'était du vrai chocolat
vous le voyez des gourmands sont
toujours attraper
alors gros source
tu as oublié ma commission un bon vieux
patron je les oublie jules mai mais
demain j'y penserai bon allons en route
bonnet les petits enfants faites de
beaux rêves
à demain à demain
[Musique]
en